the former headquarters of hoopoe alba
andrea in Klagenfurt the private
financial institution took a huge gamble
on Eastern Europe in the Balkans and
lost the Austrian state of countin is
liable for around 10 billion euros and
losses and the taxpayers have to foot
the bill west allis looks all kinds of
things are subsidized and we don't have
a say unfortunately we have to keep our
mouths shut and look on misma her
Twitter clap a hurtin on sue Sonia
quarter it's unpleasant for Canton and
all of Austria as a financial center
besides the extremely costly banking
bailout new business regulations could
also weigh on some sectors like tourism
beginning in june restaurants will have
to file taxes with electronic registers
until now that could be done on paper
entrepreneurs are opposed because the
registers are expensive and they feel
they're unfairly under suspicion right
or if they often fear that money is
changing hands illegally or people are
not reporting all of their revenue and
don't suspect other sectors so the
restaurant owners are the black sheep of
society in search of business gastronome
and many Austrians fear it will be
costly for taxpayers to integrate the
95,000 asylum seekers that have come to
the country since last year but the
migrants are not simply a burden they
also help to bolster the economy it does
suck not good enough fun they create
demand especially for domestic products
such as food beverages housing services
and health care that's a boost of around
a quarter of a percent and we have a tax
reform that's taking effect this year so
that should also lift growth and began
treating the Austrian economy is
expected to expand by around one and a
half percent this year automobile
producer magnus daya has expanded its
customer base which already includes
Mercedes that's creating new jobs but
it's not easy non wage labor costs such
as social security contributions are
among the highest in Europe so finished
products have to bring companies high
returns
but releasing to you of course our wage
structure means we can compete in the
production of less expensive vehicles
but we are competitive when it comes to
luxury models we can meet the customers
quality demands Austria still boasts one
of the EU highest living standards but
many Austrians fear that this prosperity
may not last much longer